tout est déjà trompé vous sur un terrain
d'un texto vous avez envoyé un texto à
quelqu'un roule en voyant quelqu'un a un
coût oui un truc horrible à vous avec
toutes les femmes que vous avez c'est
chaud fait une grosse gaffe fait quoi
femme un fameux en fait une femme
enfin ma femme de l'époque du parti j'ai
envoyé ses bons vient vite nous l'avait
dit ça alors là du coup thuram après
c'est un service que j'étais tellement
triste que tu partes que je t'aimerai de
revient très vite ce nom où elle était
très conne beaucoup on va prendre la
deuxième solution vous non mais vous
savez que j'ai reçu un texto un jour je
reçois un texto avec un un énorme sexe
en érection
je ne vous ai jamais envoyé de sa mort
d'une personne de couleur et le gir sac
à main à main et je vois je regarde mon
truc je vois mère de vincent mcdoom mais
est juive est insensé quoi aimer c'est
mon sexe ah oui mais j'y pourquoi tu me
vois ça vincent est en fait il s'était
trompé de mathieu c'était un plan cul
qui doit avoir et qui seraient dans ton
truc estime aussi m alors non ça n'a pas
été plus loin
ça n'a pas été plus loin mais j'ai reçu
de celle que vincent
[Applaudissements]
j'adore et là normalement et la normale
après cette anecdote à nicolas pernikoff
ancien patron des divertissements de
france et vous moi georges devant omnium
texto à france 3 louis la france ô